[Music]
and now to Emma Stone she has hosted
Saturday Night Live three times but feel
a little bit more at home there than
usual and that is because emma is just
the latest star to find romance inside
Rockefeller ii so many great memories in
this place but probably the one that
sticks with me is this fling that i had
with a guy on the show back then taking
that monologue joke about an SNL romance
off script a source tells ET and the
stone and the show's writer director
dave Meharry have been casually dating
for several months okay he wants to go
back to the well the two met last
December when dave directed Emma in the
digital short wells for boys so what is
he putting in there a secret the
relationship was in full swing when Emma
made a surprise appearance during the
season 43 premiere last month
and based on what Emma told et about her
ideal chemistry recipe back in 2011 loud
and ridiculous and kind of clown like in
a way Dave sure fit the bill in July
when we interviewed the director at
Comic Con
to promote his feature brings be bare
feelin fine wine and dine cat according
to our source the couple is keeping
their relationship wonky that's similar
to the way faux a Lister Scarlett
Johansson and her boyfriend of five
months Weekend Update host Colin Jost
are handling their romance well the
first time she hosted was the first year
I was a writer on the show
meanwhile Ben Affleck and SNL producer
Lindsay shook has continued to put their
four-month relationship on full display
[Music]
you